[موسيقى]
طابع مساؤكم نحييكم ولكم التاسعه هذا
المساء هذه العناوين
حمله اوكرانيا المضاده تواجه الغام روسيا
وبوتا يستعد لحرب طويله تشكل فرصه لاهداف
داخليه
يتجاهل دعوه بوتين ويرفع وتيره الخلافات
مع وزاره الدفاع لا تقتربوا من عناصره
برلين الامن
القط
تيك توك الاسرع نموا بين تطبيقات التواصل
الاجتماعي ينافس عمالقه الاخبار وينتصر
عند الشباب
[موسيقى]
وفي تفاصيل التاسعه هذا المساء قالت
المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه روسيه ماريا
الزخرفه في مقابله مع العربيه ان العمليه
العسكريه في اوكرانيا تهدف لوقف اراقه
دماء في دومباس الذي استمر لثمانيه اعوام
زخروا فقالت ان قوات بلادها ستقضي على
الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد مشيره الى ان عده
دول قدمت رؤيتها في مبادرات لحل الازمه
الاوكرانيه الا ان المبادره الصينيه هي
الاكثر تماشيا مع نهج موسكو وتحترم سياده
روسيا ولا تؤجج الصراع كما قالت المتحدثه
باسم الخارجيه الروسيه ان هناك مبادره لحل
الازمه قدمتها جنوب افريقيا اما عن علاقات
موسكو بالدول العربيه فاكدت صخروف ان
علاقات روسيا بالدول العربيه مبنيه على
الاحترام المتبادل والمصالح المشتركه
وفي جديد الاخبار بينما تستمر الحرب في
اوكرانيا تحبس الولايات المتحده انفاسها
الى جانب حلفائها الغربيين وفي انتظار
تحقيق القوات الاوكرانيه نتائج ميدانيه
بعد دعمها باحدث التجهيزات القتاليه
نار الحرب في اوكرانيا تستمر في التهام
الاخضر واليابس اصوات القصف تكاد لا تنقطع
بعد 16 شهرا من القتال ومع اشتداده في ظل
قيام كياف بهجوم مضاد واشنطن تحبس انفاسها
مع حلفائها الغربيين لقد انى الاوان لتحقق
اوكرانيا مكاسب دراماتيكيه على الارض بعد
استثمارات حربيه بعشرات المليارات
الوحدات الاوكرانيه تشن هجومها شرقي
البلاد لكن الامتداد الهائل للاراضي
المفخخه يعيق عمليه كياف الدبابات
الاوكرانيه تصطدم بكثافه الالغام المضاده
للدروع والافراد بحسب تقارير من ارض
المعركه لتجاوز ذلك تعتمد القوات
الاوكرانيه على اجهزه تقنيه خاصه تسمح
بازاله الالغام عن بعد ومركباتها المدرعه
ودباباتها مجهزه بما يكفي لتقويض حقول
الالغام هذه غير ان هذه القوات تواجه
تحديا يتمثل في العدد المحدود لهذه الالات
التي تتعرض لنيران المدفعيه الروسيه
ورغم تحقيقها مكاسب اضافيه تحتاج اوكرانيا
زياده في عدد الدبابات بالاضافه الى غطاء
بطائرات مقاتله لحمايه القوات البريه التي
تعمل على التقدم بحسب تحليل لصحيفه
القوه الاوكرانيه بدات هجومها باستخدام
الدبابات الغربيه والعربات المدرعه التي
تسلمتها حديثا عمليه لاستعاده اكبر قدر
ممكن من الاراضي التي تسيطر عليها روسيا
الاسبوع الاول من الهجوم شهد تحقيق وحدات
اوكرانيه مكاسب في عده اقسام من الجبهه
التي يبلغ طولها 600 ميل في جنوب وشرق
البلاد المكاسب الاوكرانيه شاقه غير ان
مشكله روسيا الكبرى تتمثل في انخفاض الروح
المعنويه لدى جنودها لمواجهه ذلك تعتمد
موسكو على القصف المكثف المواجهه مستمره
ولا افق قريب لكتابه نهايه الحرب
بلال البشتين العربيه
مشاريع حفلت بها اجنده بوتين تاخرت لعقود
في زمن السلم لكنها تحولت انجازات في زمن
الحرب فرايس روسي لم يجد ما ينافس كفاءه
الحرب في تشكيل تاريخ روسيا والعالم
وفقورن هوليسي ورغم ارهاق القوات واستنفاذ
الموارد وتحقيق نتائج توصف احيانا
بالهزيله الا ان مشروع بوتين باوكرانيا
غير اي الانتهاء قريبا بحسب المجله
العريقه بوتين يستعد لحرب طويله يتمسك بها
لجلبها فوائد كثيره كالحد من اعتماد
التجاره الروسيه على الغرب وهو هدف لم
تحققه سنوات من السياسه والاستراتيجيات
ففي عام 2022
انخفض حجم التجاره للبلاد مع اوروبا باكثر
من النصف بينما نمت تجاره مع الصين باكثر
من 40% كما تمكنت الشركات الروسيه من
تعبئه مواردها وتمويل مجموعه من مشاريع
النقل الموجهه نحو اسيا اهداف انشملت ايضا
استبدال الواردات الغربيه بالمنتجات
المحليه وقضاء الروس لعطلهم على الاراضي
الروسيه واستعاده هيبه القوات المسلحه
فالاستعداد لحرب طويله يظهر اكثر في
قراراته المتمثله بتشديد نظام التجنيد
العسكري والاستثمار على نطاق واسع في
انتاج الاسلحه واذا ما توقفت الحرب بسرعه
قد تطرح ايضا بالسرعه حول اخفاقات هذه
الحرب على كل حال نذهب الى ضيفنا من باريس
جون كير الكاتب السياسي اهلا بك السيد
جومبير معنا في التاسع هذا المساء هل
الاهداف الداخليه لبوتين التي تتحدث عنها
التقارير تستحق الرغبه بعدم وقف الحرب
فعلا
الاحوال ان من المصلحه الاستراتيجيه
لبوتين بان تطول هذه الحرب لان هذه الحرب
هي حرب اقتصاديه وسياسيه وعسكريه ايضا
ولكنها ايضا حرب في مجال الوقت وعندما
يطول الوقت هذا في مصلحه موسكو اما الوقت
القصير فهو في مصلحه الامريكيين الذين
يواجهون استحققنا انتخابيا رئيسيا في 2024
وهذا امر يجب ان اخذ اعتبار اما بالنسبه
لاوروبا فهي ترى الفاتوره الاقتصاديه
والعسكريه التي تطول في النزاع الاوكراني
نحن نرى بان هناك
750 مليار دولار تم صرفها سيكون هناك حاجه
ل 750 مليار دولار لاعاده اعمار اوكرانيا
وهذا امر او هذا مبلغ كبير اذا وقت اذا
مطال يصب في مصلحه موسكو وفي كل الاحوال
ان الاهداف العسكريه الاساسيه لموسكو لم
تحقق بعد وهنا نتذكر ما قاله بوتين في
البدايه وبان اوكرانيا ليست موجوده بين
الامه الاوكرانيه والثقافه الاوكرانيه
ليست موجوده وبالتالي اوكرانيا ليست
موجوده وهذا هو الهدف الحربي الحقيقي
لروسيا
وبالتالي في المقابل الهدف العسكري
الاوكراني موجود لان اوكرانيا تقاوم
روسيا عقب اطلاق الصاروخ الاول قبل اكثر
من عام اطلقت اسم العمليه العسكريه الخاصه
هل هذا يعني بان روسيا لم تكن تريد حربا
شامله ولكنها اخطات التقدير
ان روسيا بالفعل اساءت الحسابات وقال
بوتين شخصيا بان الحرب كانت ستستمر اربعه
ايام لكن لم يكن ذلك صوره من صور البيان
كان ذلك هدفا عسكريا حقيقيا بان يدوم او
تستمر العمليات اربعه ايام وان تسقط
اوكرانيا ولكن معركه
خسرت المعركه الروسيه وقد انتصرت اوكرانيا
في هذه المعركه ومن ذلك الحين منذ معركه
كيف تستمر هذه الحرب وانا اعتقد شخصيا
بانه لن يكون هناك اي مفاوضات اتيه في
الافق لان على روسيا اوكرانيا ان يحقق
النصر لكي يبدا اي شكل من اشكال
المفاوضات ولا اسم هنا بعد لكن اليس النصر
الذي تتحدث عنه هو سلاح ذو حدين يعني
اليست الدول الاوروبيه والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه بدعمها عسكريا لكيف ساهمت بشكل
او باخر باطاله امد الحرب
بان الحرب تستمر بسبب
الدور الذي تلعبه الدول الغربيه وخاصه
امريكا وحلفائها لان امريكا لم تقدم بسرعه
الاسلحه والذخائر التي كانت بحاجه لها
اوكرانيا قدمت مقدمته بشكل
تدريجي لقد تاخروا كثيرا في تقديم ما
تحتاج اليه اوكرانيا ان ذلك لم يصب في
مرحله او في مصلحه اوكرانيا ولكن الان مع
تسليم الاوكرانيين مقاتلات من طراز اف 16
وهذه من اوروبا وليست من امريكا
نحن نتكلم بان لدى اوكرانيا من الان
وصاعدا تسليحا معقدا متقدما وحقيقيا ولكن
اذا ما واجهنا او راينا الى الاسلحه التي
يحملها الجنود الاوكرانيون في الخنادق
سنرى ان هذه الاسلحه قديمه متهالكه
بمعظمها وان الاسلحه الفقيه حقيقيه
الجديده في طريقها وان تكوين وتدريب
الطيارين يتطلب الكثير من الوقت وحتى لو
كانت اوروبا تقدم الكثير لاسيما بريطانيا
وفرنسا شكرا جزيلا لك من باريس
الكاتب السياسي
بنظام طرد لانقاذ الطاقم غير ان سيده الجو
الجديده الاوفى في قائمه موسكو حتى اللحظه
هي مسيره
او صائده المدرعات التي طورتها شركه
كلاشنكوف هي تعد هذه المسيره لغما جويا
قاسيا يسيطر على السماء بسرعه تصل الى 300
كيلو متر في الساعه ومدى يصل الى 40
كيلومترا وتوصف بالخدومه بسبب استخدامها
في مهام الاستطلاع والهجوم وتحمل رؤوسا
شديده الانفجار او الانشطار تصل الى ثلاثه
كيلوغرامات الدقه من مميزاتها كذلك فمسيره
زال لانسيت تتمتع بتوجيه بصري وتلفزيوني
يمكنها من التحكم في توجيه ذخيره حتى في
المراحل النهائيه قبل الصياد الهدف مراوغه
تستطيع قنص اهدافها اثناء الطيران وتباغت
العدو بسبب قله الضوضاء التي يسببها
محركها الكهربائي ما يعزز من عنصر
المفاجاه
[موسيقى]
هذا المصنع الذي نتحدث عنه وفق الاتهامات
الغربيه تشيده موسكو بمساعده طهران التي
ترسل مواد لبنائه اما المده المتوقعه لبدء
الانتاج فبحسب الدفاع البريطانيه فهو مطلع
العام المقبل اي 20 24
وسرعه مخيفه بالتصنيع والشحن كشفها حطام
مسيره قرانيه اسقطت في اوكرانيا في ابره
للماضي حيث اظهر تحليل للحطام وجود اجزاء
صينيه الصنع في طائره شاهد 136 بينها محول
جهد ومصنوع في يناير الماضي وفق
الاكتشاف يظهر مدى سرعه تصنيع ايران
للمسيرات وشحنها الى روسيا فالجزء الصيني
صنع في منتصف شهر يناير ثم شحن الى ايران
ليتم تركيبه في الطائره قبل ارسالها الى
موسكو تعد هذه المره الاولى التي يعثر
فيها على جزء مصنوعه من 2023 في المسيرات
الايرانيه علما بان روسيا اطلقت اكثر من
700 طائره من دون طياره لاستهداف محطات
توليد الكهرباء والمدن والاهداف العسكريه
وفقا للجيش الاوكراني وبحسب الاداره
الامريكيه طهران ارسلت الشهر الماضي مئات
الطائرات على مدن مد سفن تمر عبر بحر
قزوين موسكو الامداداتها من المسيرات
دائره الانتاج النشطه اذا هذه وضع تحديات
جديده امام واشنطن وحلفائها تتمثل بمحاوله
وقف تدفق كل المكونات من جميع انحاء
العالم باتجاه روسيا الى مصانع المسيرات
الايرانيه
غلطه الشاطر بالف لكن العبره في تعلم
الخطا هفوات فادحه كثيره وقعت بها موسكو
دفعتها لتطوير اسلحتها ومهاراتها جنرال
بريطاني متقاعد اكد انشاء الجيش الروسي
لخطوط دفاعيه شديده التحصين على طول خط
المواجهه الذي يبلغ طوله الف كيلومتر
اوضحت موسكو تعلمت ابقاء المواقع المهمه
مثل مقر القياده مخازن ذخيره خارج نطاق
المدفعيه فوكاله السوشيت بريس اكدت ان
موسكو تعلمت من محاولتها الفاشله للسلعه
على كيف وذلك حين تقدمت القوافل العسكريه
الروسيه لاميال لتصبح فريسه سهله للمدفعيه
والمسيرات كما شحدت اسلحتها الالكترونيه
لتقليل التفوق الالكتروني في الطائرات
القتاليه من دون طيار وحولت القنابل
الثقيله من ترى سنتها ضخمه التي تعود
الحقبه السوفيتيه الى ذخائر انزلاقيه
موجهه بدقه هي قادره على ضرب الاهداف من
دون تعريض طائراتها الحربيه للخطر لكن ذلك
وكل رغم ذلك لا تزال روسيا تعاني نقاط ضعف
اساسيه تتمثل بالمعنويات المنخفضه لجنودها
نقص في ذخيره وسوء التنسيق بين الوحدات
[موسيقى]
على كل حال تتابعون في ملفات التاسعه بعد
قليل بعد تركيا البوسنه معقل الاخوان
الجدد في اوروبا والطلاب وصلتهم لاختراق
المجتمع
بتابع الان في الملف الاوكراني الروسي
فزعيم فاجن
يرفع التحدي امام موسكو والخصم هذه المره
ليس وزير الدفاع بل بوتين الذي طالما كان
الحكم في خلافات بريجوجين شايغو بوتين
دعاه الى توقيع عقود بين قوته والجيش
الروسي لكن صديقه القديم اعتبر طلب عارا
في غوجين اقترح حلا وسطا يحصل فيه
المتطوعون على ضمانات اجتماعيه ووثائق
كمشاركين في الاعمال القتاليه بدلا من هذه
الصفقه
عندما شاركنا لاول مره في هذه الحرب لم
يقل احد اننا سنكون مضطرين لتوقيع صفقات
مع وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
لا احد من مقاتل فاجنر مستعد للسير في
طريق العار هذا مره اخرى لهذا السبب لا
احد منهم سيوقع العقود
تساعد المساء مستمر وفي ملفاتنا بعد
الفاصل
اياد صغيره لم تجد من ياخذ بها وصلت وحيده
الى تشاد هربا من الحرب في السودان
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في تفاصيل التاسعه هذا المساء
ثبت مجلس الاحتياط الفيدرالي الامريكي
اسعار الفائده دون تغيير بين خمسه وخمسه
وربع في المئه جاء هذا القرار بعدما قام
الفيدرالي برفع اسعار الفائده بشكل متتالي
وفي اخر عشره اجتماعات له ما يشكل نهايه
لتشديد السياسه النقديه والتي قام بها
لكبح ارتفاع معدلات التضخم وعزل احتياطي
الفيدرالي قراره الى ان ذلك يتيح وقتا
لتقييم المعلومات وتاثيرات الاضافيه على
السياسه النقديه وضاف ان تصويت على تثبيت
اسعار الفائده من قبل لجنه السياسه
النقديه جاء بالاجماع
[موسيقى]
شبكه معقده ومتراميه بناها تنظيم الاخوان
في الجزء الشرقي الاوروبي فباتت الدول شرق
اوروبا حديقه خلفيه لنشر فكر التنظيم في
قلب القاره العجوز الوجود الاخواني في هذه
البلدان يعيد للاذهان وجود تنظيم في الدول
الغربيه قبل عقود وكيف تغلغل الى هناك
دراسه حديثه لمركز توثيق الاسلام السياسي
وهو مركز حكومي في النمسا اكد ان التنظيم
اسس شبكه باتت متراميه الاطراف في بلدان
مثل البانيا
تضمنان وتضمان عددا كبيرا من المسلمين
فالاخوان استخدموا منظمتي اتحاد المنظمات
الاسلاميه والاتحاد الاسلامي للمنظمات
الطلابيه الشبابيه للتوسع في تلك البلدان
[موسيقى]
وعند الحديث عن تغلغل الاخوان شرق اوروبا
فلابد من الحديث عن البوسنه التي بدا
الاعلام الغربي بوصفها كخزان للتطرف
بتنامي نفوس تيار الاخوان فيها الشبكات
القريبه من جماعه الاخوان برزت في البوسنه
منذ اوائل التسعينات التزامن مع انشاء عدد
من المنظمات غير الحكوميه التي تدير
الخدمات الانسانيه لكنها في بعض الاحيان
قدمت الدعم للمسلحين للمشاركين في صراع
البوسنه في ذلك الوقت تحت الستار العمل
الانساني تقرير مركز توثيق الاسلام
السياسي في النمسا قال ان معظم الاخوان
الذين نشطوا في البوسنه وحتى المناطق
المجاوره لها خلال الحرب تركوا البلاد بعد
انتهاء الصراع مع ذلك وجد التنظيم العالمي
للاخوان حلفاء في شخصيات محليه بارزه في
البوسنه مثل الرئيس السابق ايشاء
والمفتيين السابقين والحالي ايضا للبلاد
المجلس الاوروبي للفتوى المرتبط بالاخوان
بدا ايضا بتقديم دورات في سرايفو في عامي
حضر بعضها مفتي الاخوان يوسف القرضاوي
انذاك منظمه اخرى عضو في اتحاد المنظمات
الاسلاميه في اوروبا شكلت مظله الاخوان في
القاره ايضا وهي جمعيه الثقافه والتعليم
والرياضه في البوسنه رغم هذه هذا التمدد
والاتصالات رفيعه المستوى لتنظيم الى ان
الوجود الاخواني في البوسنه يمكن وصفه
بالصغير نسبيا في الحجم والتاثير وفق مركز
الاسلام السياسي بالنمسا ايضا
[موسيقى]
نذهب الان الى القاهره عمر فاروق الباحث
في شؤون الجماعات المتطرفه استاذ عمرو
اهلا بك معنا في التاسعه هذا المساء لماذا
لا تزال جماعه الاخوان تحظى بدعم من بعض
المؤسسات الاوروبيه وموتى قدم لتتوسع
وتتمدد
مساء الخير على حضرتك وعلى الساده
المشاهدين يعني جماعه الاخوان وتنظيمات
طيارات الاسلام السياسي هي في النهايه
جماعات ضغط وجماعات وظيفيه بيتم استثمارها
للضغط على بعض الانظمه خاصه الانظمه
العربيه الان تنظيم الاخوان يسعى للخروج
من المحاصره العربيه والاقليميه وكذلك
فقدان حواضنه في بعض الدول الكبرى
الاوروبيه ويتجه الى دول كتل الكتله
الشرقيه في اوروبا خاصه ان جماعه الاخوان
استثمارت بعض الحروق الازمات الداخليه في
هذه المناطق والحروب الاهليه وكذلك النزعه
الى مواجهه الشيوعيه وتمكنت من بناء عدد
كبير جدا من التمركزات التي تدعم الخطاب
الايدولوجي لجماعه الاخوان على مدار
السنوات السابقه خاصه منذ بدايه التسعينات
وبعدين كمان ان هنجد ان قسم
الاطفال بالعالم الخارجي اللي موجود داخل
الاخوان وهو النواه الاولى لتنظيم الدولي
بدا مبكرا في تاسيس عدد من الخلايا داخل
بعض الدول العربيه والاوروبيه كذلك لان
الاخوان
استغلوا الطلاب الوافدين من دول اوروبا
الشرقيه للدراسه في الازهر الشريف خاصه
المسلمين اللي كانوا بيجوا يدرسوا في
الازهر الشريف ويتاثروا او يتم استقطابهم
عن طريق عناصر جماعه الاخوان وتمددوا في
هذه الدول وبداوا في بناء مرتكزات خاصه
بهم ومنهم طبعا علي عزت بيجوفيتش اللي هو
كان الرئيس يعني رئيس البوسنه والهرسك في
مرحله التسعينات الان جماعه الاخوان
بتمتلك علاقات على المستوى الرئاسي
والحكومي وكذلك مستوى المؤسسات المجتمع
المدني داخل البوسنه والهرسك وده اللي
بيؤهلها انها تكون مركز جديد
يعني نقل استثمارات التنظيم لان الاخوان
لديهم استثمارات على مستوى التعليم وبناء
عدد من المدارس الخاصه وبناء عدد من
الجامعات يعني لديهم جامعه خاصه داخل
شرايبه وهذه الجماعه عفوا جميعا خاصه داخل
سرايفه وهذه الجامعه لها علاقات ببعض
المؤسسات اللي موجوده في اوروبا وهناك
تعاون ممتاز كذلك الامر الاونه الاخيره
وخصوصا يعني قبل شهر من الان بدات تتخذ
اجراءات صارمه يعني
وتعي مخاطر وجود جماعه الاخوان اليوم هل
برايك كباحث في شؤون الجماعات المتطرفه
اوروبا تخشى ربما من تصنيف وحظر انشطه
جماعه الاخوان السياسيه لالا يكون هناك
حجج لان تلتحق عناصرهم بجماعات متطرفه
ويقوموا باعمال العنف في اوروبا
لا بالعكس يعني جماعه الاخوان مهدت الطريق
لنشر التطرف يعني عدد كبير جدا ممن
انتمموا للتنظيمات المتطرفه هم في البدايه
تشبعوا بافكار جماعه الاخوان اوروبا الان
بتخشى من بناء المجتمعات الموازيه يعني او
خروج الامر عن السيطره لان هناك بعض الكتل
السكنيه اللي هي بتنتمي لجماعه الاخوان او
متاثره بالخطاب الفكري لجماعه الاخوان
وكذلك الخطاب السلفي المتشدد يمكن حتى هما
استثمروا هامش الحريات وتوسعوا في بناء
المراكز الاسلاميه اللي خرج منها انشطه
اخرى مختلفه يعني الامر لا يتوقف على فكره
نشر الفكر لكن هناك بعض الاستثمارات
الخاصه بجماعه الاخوان وكذلك المنظمات
المدنيه التابعه او التي تدافع عن حقوق
الانسان وبعض المؤسسات الاعلاميه وكذلك
الامر بعض المدارس التعليميه اللي موجوده
في اوروبا اللي بيتبعها التابعه بشكل
مباشر يا جماعه الاخوان كل هذه الامور في
النهايه بتصب في صالح التنظيم الدولي على
المستوى الماني وعلى المستوى الفكري هناك
استقطاب فكري واستقطاب تنظيمي وفي نفس
التوقيت هناك موارد ماليه ضخمه جدا فضلا
عن ان هم سيطروا على كعكه الصدقات
والتبرعات الخاصه بالجاليات العربيه
والاسلاميه اللي موجوده في اوروبا كل هذه
الامور بدت تكون مؤشر خطر
يعني المؤسسات الامنيه اللي موجوده في
اوروبا اللي هي الان ربما احنا بنقول ان
هناك استفاقه ولكنها اتفاقها متاخره شكرا
جزيلا الشكر عدد كبير في هذا الموضوع ولكن
في الوقت من القاهره عمر فاروق الباحث في
شؤون الجماعات المتطرفه شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
كشف المستشار الالماني عن استراتيجيه
جديده للامن القومي تركز على امن الطاقه
والصين ووصف استراتيجيه الامن القومي
الالماني وصف وصفه روسيا بانها اكبر تهديد
جدي للنظام الدولي واوروبا كملصت على ان
روسيا تهدد الديمقراطيه في اوروبا ويجب
التصدي لها وشددت الاستراتيجيه الجديده
على ضروره التزام بمسار النيتو وتخصيص
اثنين في المئه من الناتج لانفاق الدفاعي
استراتيجيه الامن القومي الالماني طالبت
ايضا بانشاء مركز فيدرالي لمواجهه الهجمات
الخارجيه بينما حضرت وزيره الخارجيه
الالمانيه من ان الامن في القرن الحادي
والعشرين يعني الا تتجسس الصين على
الهواتف
وبالحديث عن الصين والامن الحروب تخلع
تدريجيا عباءه المواجهه التقليديه التي
تخيطها قوه الاسلحه وسرعه الدبابات في ظل
تطور تكنولوجيا وعلميا مخيف معارك صامته
ومواجهته شفرات لا دمويه سيناريو متوقعه
للصراع او حرب مقبله قد تندلع بين واشنطن
وبكين عنوانه العريض التخريب الالكتروني
والهجمات السيبرانيه ففي وقت انقلبت سيدات
السماء او المسيرات الانتحاريه قواعد
اللعبه في حرب اوكرانيا يتوقع ان تهجر اي
حرب مفترضه بين الجانبين الاجواء العاليه
لتتغلغل في البنيه التحتيه التوتر
المتصاعد بين البلدين دفع مسؤولين في مجال
الامن الالكتروني الى التحذير من عمل
قراصنه الصينيين على تعطيل البنيه التحتيه
الحيويه في الولايات المتحده مثل خطوط
الانابيب والسكك الحديديه التهديد وصف
بالحقيقي نسيم نبكين توجه استثمارات ضخمه
لتعزيز حجم قدرات والموارد والجهود التي
تبذلها من اجل ذلك لا بل تبرز حاجه ضروريه
لاستعداد لهو التركيز عليه وتطوير قدره
على مجابهته للحد من اضراره في العالم
المادي والحيلوله دون احداثه الاضطرابات
اذا تحضيرات مماثله اطلقتها دوائر
استخباراتيه امريكيه عن دراسه بكين
بالتاكيد لعمليات الكترونيه عدوانيه ضد
البنيه التحتيه الحيويه الامريكيه وضد
اهداف عسكريه في حال استشعر صناع القرار
الصينيين بمعركه وشيكا كما ارتفعت خلال
الاشهر الماضيه حده الاتهامات الامريكيه
لبكين بشن حملات تجسس بمختلف الاشكال
والوسائل على مرافق امريكيه حساسه
[موسيقى]
الدكتور حسين العمري استاذ علم الحاسوب
وخبير تكنولوجيا المعلومات في سيليكون ذلك
دكتور حسين مرحبا بك معنا في التاسعه هذا
المساء صرنا نسمع عن مصطلح الحرب العالميه
الرقميه الاولى دول عده تخشى من الهجمات
السيبرانيه والالكترونيه هل هذا كلام
مبالغ فيه اليوم الكترونيه هل هذا كلام
مبالغ فيه اليوم نعم مبالغ فيه من حيث
التهويل الاعلامي وهو يفيد طبعا الحكومات
في الضغط الدول الغربيه في امريكا نعيش في
امريكا طبعا يخافون ويوافقون على الصرف
الحكومي على هذه الاشياء التي تكون عاده
بقرارات من الناس يعني التهويل الاعلام
مفيد من هذه الناحيه لتخويف الناس ان هناك
بعض يعني يجب علينا ان نعمل جاهدين في هذا
المجال الصراع بين الصين
قائم جدا عشان تفهم بخفيته هو شوفوا لن
تكون هناك حرب عالميه وقنابل نوويه وهذا
كله طبعا كلام فاضي تهويل الاعلام صحفيين
كلام صحفيين لكن الصين والهند قادتان يعني
غصب عننا في العالم
لمن دكتور حسين لمن الغلبه الان في الحرب
السيبرانيه بين الصين والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه خصوصا وان هناك من يقول بان
الصين بنت الجدار النار العظيم على غرار
سور الصين العظيم
لا يوجد غلبه طبعا زي ما قلت لك لازم نعزل
الهند الهند في مهتمه فقط بالصف لكن انا
في امريكا معظم الصناعات
الالكترونيه هذا التكنولوجيا اتصالات
الجيل الخامس والجيل السادس كل هذه ذهبت
الى الصين بينما البرامج ذهبت الى الهند
مع بعض يشكل 36% بالعالم الصين
من سكان العالم فوجودها مش دوله صغيره
يعني القنابل النوويه يخلص منها بيوم
وليله يعني هذا يتم ضرب مفاعل في الدوله
الفلانيه والفلانيه لكن تتكلم انت الان عن
خمس سكان الكره الارضيه وعندهم ليس تركيب
التركيز على منتجات تكفي العالم مثلا
الغذاء العالم معظمهم ناتي من الصين لو
ضربت الصين العالم سيجور ونفس الشيء
الاجهزه الالكترونيه الان في عندك انت
سياسه
يا دكتور حسين امكانيه تنفيذ اعجابات يعني
انت عندك الحرب السبراليه طبعا في ثلاث
فروع لها في اول شيء التكنولوجيا انت عندك
الشرائح الالكترونيه هذه كلها تايوان مثلا
تايوان في المتخصصه في الشرائح لا اكثر من
90% يعني حواليون بتقريبا مليون مليون
شريحه سنويا
اليوم تخشى من تيك توك اللي هو خرج لفئه
الشباب واللي بهالفيديوهات فما بالك يعني
هذا تطبيق
وتطبيقيه بالاساس وتعتبره خطر على الامن
القومي الامريكي ما بالك اذا ما تمادت
الصين اكثر فاكثر في تطبيقاتها وفي حربها
التكنولوجيه لا لا الهجمات من الطرفان من
الطرفين يعني لا شك امريكا والصين طبعا
الاعلام الامريكي اقوى من الاعلام الصين
لكن الهجمات موجوده عند الطرفين
في اللي هو يدخل فيها الصناعات ويدخل فيها
البرمجيات ويدخل فيها الان الذكاء الصناعي
الان ولذلك قام بحضره هواوي والتيك توك
وغيره في امريكا لانه فيها وسائل للتجسس
على الناس وكيف لكن
التجسس شوفوا التجسس
يعني امريكا اقوى دوله من ناحيه التجسس
لكن التجسد لصالح الصين ليش لانه امريكا
بلد مهاجرين فكثير من المهاجرين في امريكا
عندنا من الصين بينما لا يوجد مهاجرين
امريكان في الصين الان هذولا معاهم جنسيه
صينيون يشتغلون في اعلى المراكز الشركات
على المراكز الجامعات
فهؤلاء عندهم ازدواج جنسيه فهل تثق فيهم
ام لا انت بلد ديمقراطي المفروض تثق بيهم
فالديمقراطيه هنا تاتي لتضرب هذا الموضوع
انه انت اذا كنتمقراطي المفروض تسمح له او
لا الشكر دكتور حسين وننوه بانه حديثنا عن
الخشيه من الهجمات والحروب السيبرانيه
وليست تجسس من سانتا كلارا دكتور حسين
العمري استاذ علم الحاسوب وخبير تكنولوجيا
المعلومات في سيليكون فالي
[موسيقى]
اياد صغيره متروكه لا تلقى من يمسكها
فالخوف من الحرب دفعهم للهروب ليستيقظوا
في امان الوحده ببلد اخر منظمه يونيسف دقت
ناقوس الخطر مع تاكيدها عبور مئات الاطفال
غير المصحوبين بدويهم الحدود التشاديه
للفرار من القتال في السودان حيث ادى
القتال الى فصل العائلات اجبار القاصرين
على القيام بالرحله الشاقه عبور حدود تمتد
على طول الف كيلو متر دون والديهم اضافه
ان المزيد والمزيد للاطفال يصلون بمفردهم
الى البلد المجاور الذي فر اليه اكثر من
مئه الف لاجئ 60% منهم دون سن 18 عاما
المدير القطري لمنظمه يونيسف في تشاد جاك
بويل اكد تحديدا 267 طفلا غير مصحوبين
بدويهم حتى اللحظه مرجحا ان يكون رقم
الحقيقي اكثر بكثير لفت الى صعوبه هذه
الصعوبه وصعوبه مهمه لم الشمل او تحديد
مكان الوالدين بسبب طول الحدود بين
البلدين كما ذكرنا وضعف شبكه الاتصالات
وعدم تسجيل العائلات وحتى الاطفال بشكل
صحيح في المخيمات الرسميه هذا وحضرت
وكالات الاغاثه من ان القصه غير المصحوبين
بدويهم هم الاكثر ضعفا نظرا الى ان عماله
الاطفال او الاستغلال الجنسي تشكلان خطرا
حقيقيا
[موسيقى]
التاسع هذا المساء مستمره ونتابع في
سياقها ولكن بعد قليل
رئيس بلديه باريس يطالب السكانه بالتعايش
مع الجرذان
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في التاسعه هذا المساء ضحيه
لاضطهاد سياسي ونظام فاسد هكذا صور الرئيس
الامريكي السابق تونيل نفسه امام انصاره
بعد انتهاء جلسته امام القضاء في ميامي
دفوع ترامب القانونيه ضد الاتهامات
المواجهه ضده كانت متوقعه بداها بالتاكيد
على براءته في تهمه عرقله العداله وتعريض
الامن القومي للخطر ترامب قال انه تعامل
بشكل ايجابي مقارنه بالطريقه التي تعامل
بها رؤساء الاخرون مع الوثائق الحساسه
الرئيس السابق الطامح للسعاده منصبه في
انتخابات 20 24 اعتبر ان كل هذه الاتهامات
هدفها الاضرار بحملته الرئاسيه ترامب
اعتبر خضوعه للمحاكمه عار في تاريخ امريكا
واصفا بايدن بالرئيس الاكثر فسادا في
تاريخ الولايات المتحده طبعا لن يترك
ترامب هذه الفرصه تمر دون تذكير
الامريكيين بانجازاته مؤكدا انه الوحيد
القادر على انقاذ امريكا
[موسيقى]
مطارده الساحرات زيف غير مؤذن جماهريا ام
فخ يسحب ترامب من كرسي رئا فرئيسه
الامريكي السابق خرج من باحه المحكمه
لتخرج معه تحليلات عن مدى تاثير هذه التهم
الثقيله وزنا وعددا على حظوظه بالانتخابات
المقبله وعلى حريتها اساسا قائمه التهم
دون شك عززت موقفه ترامب داخل الحزب
الجمهوري فاعضاء الحزب وضعوا الملاحقه
القضائيه في اطار تسليح نظام العداله
والمعايير المزدوجه بالمقابل رجح سياسيون
امريكيون اضرار لائحه الاتهام بفرص اعاده
انتخاب ترامب مع تهديدها بخساره اصوات
مستقلين الذين يمثلون بيضه القبان
بالانتخابات لاسيما ان ادله الادعاء العام
شملت تسجيلات المزعومه للرئيس السابق
يتحدث فيها عن سجلات سريه امام اناس غير
مخولين بالاطلاع عليها مستشار ترامب
السابق للامن القومي من جهه اوضح ان
اللائحه الاتهام مكتوبه بدقه
قد تنهي حياه ترامب السياسيه وتؤدي به الى
السجن لكن يبقى الوصف الاشد وقعا وقوف
الناخب الامريكي امام نوعين من الفوضى
الاختيار الاولى سياسيه واجتماعيه يخلقها
ترامب والثانيه فوضى اقتصاديه يخلقها
[موسيقى]
ونذهب الى واشنطن من امام بيت الابيض
مديره مكتب العربيه ناديه بلبيسي ناديه
اهلا بك معنا في التاسعه هذا المساء في كل
قضيه يدان بها ترامب يعرف كيف يستثمرها
ماذا عن القضيه الاخيره
اهلا بك نادين بالفعل ما استطاعت رمب ان
يفعله ليله امس مجرد خروجه من المحكمه في
ميامي وذهابي الى نيوجيرسي هو ان يجمع
اثنين مليون دولار في اقل من ساعات يعني
في المحكمه الاخيره في نيويورك استطاع ان
يجمع اربع ملايين في 48 ساعه نتحدث الان
عن ساعات فقط ليس اكثر وبالتالي الرئيس
معروف بانه يوظف كل الازمات الى فرص
يستفيد منها في جمع الاموال وفي حشد
التاييد التاييد الذي يبقى يعني على ما
كان عليه منذ ان ترشح للرئاسه عام 2016
30% تقريبا هذه الشريحه الوفيه المخلصه له
في الحزب الجمهوري بقي معه بغض النظر عن
كل التهم لكن هذه ليست كافيه لايصاله الى
خلفي الى البيت الابيض هنا لانه كما
تعرفين الناخبين المستقلين هم الذين
يقررون الانتخابات الرئاسيه بعد اذا
افترضنا بانه بالفعل فاز بترشح الحزب
الجمهوري في الانتخابات الاوليه والتي
ستعقد خلال عام من الان بين الان وبين
المحاكمه وبين الملاحقه القانونيه واذا
كان بالفعل سيكون هناك سيكون هناك وسجن لا
نعرف اذا يستطيع اذا كان الرئيس ترامب
يستطيع ان يبقي على تربعه على راس الهرم
من الان وحتى الصيف القادم طيب ناديه لو
تحدثين عن استراتيجيه الهجوم التي اتبعها
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب علي وعلى
اعدائي فتح النار على الجميع امس
بالفعل يعني بالامس كان خطابه موجه الى
هجوم قوي
وربما حاد ليس فقط على الشخصيات التي
استمعنا لها في السابق عندما الرئيس كان
يهاجم ويقول بانها اخفت او محت 33 الف
ايميل او ايضا عندما يتحدث عن بايدن الذي
احتفظ به وثائق عندما كان نائب للرئيس لكن
ايضا هاجم الرئيس بوش وقال بانه في عهد
الرئيس بوش كان هناك اختفاء 22 مليون
ايميل كان المفروض ان يبقوا في حيازه
الدوله ايضا هاجم الرئيس بلكلينتون الذي
قال بانه اضع الشفره النوويه وبالتالي هو
يحاول ان يبرر هذه الاتهامات بدلا من
الدفاع عنه بالهجوم على كل الرؤساء
السابقين وطبعا نواب الرؤساء ليقول بان
هناك ازدواجيه بالمعايير بانه الهدف لانه
ضحيه لان هناك دوله عميقه تمنع او تريد
منع ترشحه للرئاسه وعلى فكره حتى في عهد
هيلر كلينتون وانا واياك تحدثنا اكثر من
مره كان بامكاني عندما اتى للبيت الابيض
ان يفتح تحقيق في موضوع السيرفر التي ابقت
على الايميل الخاص في منزلها الى اخره لكن
هو نفسه حتى لم يستطع لانه وزاره العدل لم
تجد ادله كافيه يمكن ان تفتح فيها تحقيقا
طيب حتى ناديه كنا تحدثنا ولو نفهم هذه
النقطه انه يمكن لترامب ان يحظى بالفوز
بالترشح عن الحزب الجمهوري لكنه لن يصل
الى البيت الابيض كيف يمكن ان نفهم ذلك
هناك عمليه
انتخابيه
احيانا تبدو معقده لكنه هي ايضا سهله يعني
من ناحيه لشرحها للمشاهدين اولا في الحزب
هناك فقط حزبان ديمقراطي وجمهوري في
الولايات المتحده كل حزب يمر بعمليه ما
تسمى بالانتخابات الاوليه وبالتالي بامكان
ترامب حتى الان كما تعرفين ان يفوز بهذا
الترشح لانه على كل الولايات الجمهوريه
واحيانا نواب مستقلين ان يصوتوا له ليحصل
على الاغلبيه في تصويت الحزب الجمهوري
طبعا هذه الانتخابات وحتى الان كل نسب
الاستطلاع استطلاعات الراي تعطيه 62% من
اصوات الحزب الجمهوري بعده ياتي روند 26%
والباقي كلها نسب ضئيله يعني 3% 5% لنيكي
هيلي او مايك بينس وبالتالي كل يعني
التوقعات تشير الى انه ترامب بالفعل سيكون
مرشح على حزب الجمهوري لكن
سفينه الصحافه التقليديه اخذه بالغرق شيئا
فشيئا بل يتكسر جليدها على منصات التواصل
المشتعله تقرير لمعهد رويترز لدراسه صحافه
اكد تراجع نسبه الحاصلين على الاخبار من
مواقع الكترونيه او تطبيقات بعشر نقاط منذ
2018 اكد الى الشباب اهتماما اكبر بمشاهير
وبمؤثرين وشخصيات معروفه على وسائل
التواصل مقارنه بصحفيين تيك توك هو الاسرع
نموا بين وسائل التواصل وفق التقرير اذ
يستخدمه للاخبار عشرون في المئه ممن
ينتمون للفئه العمريه بين 18 و 24 عاما اي
بزياده قدرها خمس نقاط مئويه عن العام
الماضي ابدى 48% من المشاركين اهتماما
بالاخبار من الاساس بعد ان سجل عام 2007
عشر 63 في المئه منهم فيما فضل اقل من ثلث
المشاركين اختيار القصص الاخباريه لهم من
خلال الخوارزميات
اكثر من ان يختارها لهم رؤساء تحرير او
صحفيون هذا وانخفضت ثقه اكثر من 56% من
المشتركين بالاخبار حيث ابدو قلقه من عدم
القدره على التمييز بين الاخبار الحقيقيه
والزائفه ارتكز تقرير على مسح عبر
الانترنت شارك فيه حوالي 94 الف بالخ في
46 سوقا من بينها الولايات المتحده
[موسيقى]
يحضر خبراء اجتماعيون ونفسيون مما يصفونهم
بالخطر الكبير الذي يهدد المجتمع اللبناني
مع تكشف ارقام مرتفعه لحاله الانتحار
مؤخرا
وضع معيشي صعب وتحديات اقتصاديه واجتماعيه
تبدو حلولها صعبه التحقيق هذا الحال دفع
الياس للتسلل الى نفوس بعض اللبنانيين
خلال الاشهر الثلاثه الاولى من العام
الحالي وثقت احصاءات رسميه ست وثلاثين
حاله انتحار فيما سجلت احصاءات اخرى 50
حاله انتحارا خلال اربعه اشهر
من قدام عيوني
عم يتعذبوا بقدر اعلمهن لا حكمهن قررت
انهي حياتي خلاص انا قلت برتاح يعني انه
انا برتاح ورب العالمين تولى امر المعالجه
النفسيه في جمعيه امبريس تقول انه في
العام الماضي سجلت
138 حاله انتحار فيما سجل منذ بدايه هذا
العام 38 حاله لافته الى ان هذه الارقام
قد لا تكون دقيقه لان الكثير من حالات
الانتحار لا يعلن عنه الانتحار لمساله
كتير معقده ما الا رابط واحد هي نتيجه
تراكمات عديده بتصير اكيد اكيد
المساله الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه اللي صارت
بلبنان اثرت على الاشخاص اللي عندهم مرض
نفسي ولكن ما في يقول انه هي الرابط
الوحيد يشهد لبنان منذ عام 2019 ازمه
اقتصاديه وماليه صنفها البنك الدولي بين
الازمات الثلاث الاسوا في العالم منذ
منتصف القرن التاسع عشر
وتؤثر هذه الازمه بشده على الاوضاع
الاجتماعيه للبنانيين وتعرقل حصولهم على
الخدمات الاساسيه كما تتسبب بتدهور
الاوضاع الانسانيه نور الحصن العربيه
[موسيقى]
اثار تصريح لرئيس بلديه باريس طالب فيه
سكان العاصمه الفرنسيه بايجاد خطه للتعايش
مع الجرذان اثار موجه جدل واسعه بين من
يدعون لايجاد خطه لقتلها وبين مؤسسات
الرفق بالحيوان التي تطرح خططا بديله يبدو
ان الجرذان في باريس قد خرجت عن السيطره
اذ يقدر عددها اليوم بنحو خمسه ملايين جرد
تعيش في الشوارع والحدائق وتشكل هاجسا
يوميا للسكان
لا تفكروا كثيرا هو بالفعل كما تظنون
جوردن عملاق صوره احد السياح تحت ابرز
معالم اوروبا جمالا وسحرا برج ايفل في
العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس التي تعاني من غزو
الجرذان حتى ان احدها دخل في معطف هذه
السيده خلال مقابله تلفزيونيه
في فيلم رسوم متحركه راتا توي او الفار
الطباخ والحائز على جائزه اوسكار تقترب
الفئران كثيرا من البشر حتى انها تبتكر
وصفه طعام تلقى اعجاب الجميع وربما هذا ما
قصدته رئيسه بلديه باريس التي اثارت موجه
جدل كبيره عندما قالت ان الحل لانتشار
الجرذان هو التعايش معها
لدي مقترح لتشكيل لجنه لاستكشاف ما اذا
كان ينبغي على المواطنين في العاصمه باريس
ان يتعلموا التعايش السلمي الى جانب
الفئران بدلا من محاوله القضاء عليها سنضع
موقعا الكترونيا لمساعده السكان على
القيام ببعض التقنيات بخصوص ذلك لننظر الى
نيويورك وكيف يتم التعامل مع الامر
يعيش في باريس عاصمه الجمال والموضه
والانوار مليون انسان ونحو خمسه ملايين
جوردن باتت تشكل هاجسا يوميا للسكان لا
سيما عندما يتذكرون انها كانت سببا في
الطاعون الاسود الذي ضرب اوروبا في القرن
الرابع عشر وقتل ثلث سكانها في بضعه اعوام
[موسيقى]
رداء الجبال البركانيه القاتم المرصع
بالصخور الناريه زينته خيوط اللهب الحمراء
في اكثر من قاره فبعد ايطاليا بركان مايون
في الفلبين بدا بنفس حمم بركانيه مضطره
اكثر من 13 الف شخص بالفعل للفرار تخوفا
من حدوث انفجار بركاني ضخم وفي هواي
الامريكيه تواصل الحمم البركانيه ثيابها
من فوهه بركان كيلاويا بعد توقف ثلاثه
اشهر علما بانه يعد احد اكثر البراكين
نشاطا في العالم لكنه وفق جيولوجيين لا
يهدد حاليا اي مجتمعات في الجزيره الكبيره
مخافه احزان قراءها الاوكرانيين ونزولا
عند طلبهم الغت الروائيه الامريكيه
اليزابيث طرح كتابها الجديد غابه الثلج
بسبب حبكته التي تدور في روسيا مؤلفه كتاب
ايت
الشهير طبعا اكدت عدم رغبتها بالاضافه الى
الام اشخاص يعانون لافته الى ان الان ليس
الوقت المناسب لنشر كتابها الجديد اوضحت
الكاتبه تلقيها لموجه ردود وتعليقات من
قراء اوكرانيين عبروا عن غضبهم وخيبه
املهم والمهم بقرارها بنشر الكتاب الذي
تدور احداثه في سيبيريا بغض النظر عن
موضوعه علما بان الكتابه يحكي قصه مجموعه
افراد قرروا الانسحاب من المجتمع لمقاومه
النظام السوفيتي ودفاع عن الطبيعه في
مواجهه المد الصناعي
في نهايه التاسعه هذا المساء لم يبقى الا
ان نذكر بالعناوين
حمله اوكرانيا المضاده تواجه الغامه روسيا
وبوتين يستعد لحرب طويله تشكل فرصه لاهداف
داخليه
وزعيم فاجنر يتجاهل دعوه بوتين ويرفع
وتيره الخلافات مع وزاره الدفاع لا تقترب
من عناصره
الامن القومي تزيد من احتدام السباق الامن
مع الصين والتكنولوجيا ترسم معركه
المستقبل
رويتر تؤكد تيك توك الاسرع نموا بين
تطبيقات التواصل الاجتماعي ينافس عمالقه
الاخبار وينتصر عند الشباب
تاسع هذا المساء انتهت ولكن اخبارنا
بالتاكيد مستمره بعد قليل 360 ساعه
اخباريه مختلفه مع راويه وطاهره يسعد
مساكم مساء الخير
نادين سنتحدث طبعا عن حرب التجسس وفصولها
المتعدده بين الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
والصين النزاع بين وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
وقوات باجنر مستمر باجنر تصف قرارات وزاره
الدفاع وتحديدا بالعار وكذلك نفتح ملف
الطاقه النظيفه مجددا مع تخليفها الكثير
من المواد السامه ابقي معنا متابعه طيب
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج وال
قصص والاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات